green live prima diretta in assoluto su
youtube non ha idea di stiamo live è
veramente non so nemmeno se esistenti
the oc e inizio a vedere
ciao ciao dio siamo già il 500 ok siamo
già in mille audio dio
penso che stanno arrivando nelle
notifiche allora ora avido momento anche
la stories membri di ilsa graham che
siamo in live perché così prendono anche
loro allora un momento che faccio una
storia ed allora siamo ora live su
youtube quindi correte subito sul canale
e unitevi allo store sterili siamo già
ora in live quindi correte solida ok
questo lo abbiamo fatto allora che ora
state è la prima live che facciamo per
loro o emozionati
volevamo appunto per casa live per
rispondere a qualcuna delle vostre
domande sulla sigla innanzitutto la
lista abbiamo detto quindi contro i
commenti e siamo felicissimi che mi sta
piacendo tantissimo anzi avrebbe detto
che avete già imparato a memoria la
canzone super contenti insomma chi le
dici qualcosa a farsi qualche domanda al
riguardo della sigla vediamo se possiamo
rispondere perché alcune cose non
vogliamo svelarvi le perché non vogliamo
spoilerarvi troppo tanti commenti
dicevano che era molto orecchiabile che
quindi era fascista di portare che
avevano paura di ricordarsi
mare ha cantato da nei prossimi giorni e
quello che è successo anche a noi
abbiamo sempre in testa veramente allora
vedo che le uniche domande sono quando
disputate quando pare di un figlio ma è
stato amico sta spiando che dorme resto
però vogliamo delle domande sulla sigla
allora vediamo se riusciamo a prepararle
qualcuno lassù sforna velocissimi allora
giulia scrive chi l'ha disegnata allora
non sono io ad aver creato le animazioni
3d anche perché ci vuole insomma un po
di talento e aver studiato i programmi
per farlo ma le ha fatte
mio fratello è un suo collega amico
manuele sia molto lo stesso tutti
prendono tutto poi chi sono gli altri
personaggi allora non di spoiler chiamo
già però se ci sono altri personaggi più
forza ce ne saranno anche altri andando
avanti nella serie dobbiamo vedere un po
come si svilupperà il tutto prassi ci
sono altri due personaggi che di sì
diciamo zaino disco ilaria comunque sono
dei personaggi fantastici vi piaceranno
sicuramente allora mattino ma è un mini
film
no è una serie animata di bob carlton e
ai una maglia bellissimo e grazie a che
allora scusate non riescono veramente
velocisti in qualcuno ha scritto che
cantano un campo io la cantata una
campagna appunto mi avete scritto ma lei
canta l'altro va completamente diversa
la voce quindi non so la storia di cosa
parlerà allora è una storia ovviamente
fantasy in cui c'entra la galassia ai
vari pianeti e la magia soprattutto e
poi ci saranno anche delle varie
trasformazioni dei personaggi che è una
delle cose mi piace di più perché si
trasformerà
vedrete che ovviamente i vestiti sono
bellissimi poi vediamo dove andrà in
onda dice alessia andrà in onda sul mio
canale appunto a cosa ispirata alla
serie ci sono un bel po di ispirazioni
ma vediamo se riuscite accoglierle voi
magari vedendo piano piano la serie ma
c'è un vitale c non avete riconosciuto a
beck era molto più magro o il
personaggio
ecco i quattro personaggi dice sì alla
vita che vuole e poi gli altri quando
inizia la serie allora non vi possiamo
dare una data esatta perché stiamo
sviluppando ancora delle cose però vi
dico che probabilmente sarà a fine
giugno probabilmente coinciderà con la
fine della scuola però non è sicura al
cento per cento quindi landi grigia però
comunque non vi preoccupate perché via
twitter o comunque vi ve lo dirò nei
video e in tutto allora quanto durerà la
serie ancora dobbiamo vedere quanto
farla durare vitale mangia troppo tempo
leggermente le trova balance novità le
mangia allora sì calcio maggio quante
stagioni ci saranno per ora una poi
vedremo
per caso che fra i personaggi non ci
stia merlino machista magari in futuro
quanto tempo dura la live
non lo so
dobbiamo vedervi che andiamo in via
insomma questi dati che abbiamo come non
abbiamo un carcerato non tantissimo ai
già preparato non ho visto ti tingere i
capelli non c'entra niente questa
domanda però si sta pensando se tornare
crosta devono decidere ancora troppo
veloce ma berlino melania rea dormendo
diteci cosa ne pensate della sigla di
tesi che impressione vi ha fatto cosa vi
è piaciuto siamo super curiosi di
sentire le vostre opinioni
troppo veloce adesso chiudo la
distinzione se non si può allora del
timone stupenda che ma qualcuno ha
donato un euro donato e niente
[Risate]
bellissimo ma chi sono gli altri due
personaggi sono dei personaggi
fantastici e però non vogliamo
spoilerarvi troppo perché piano piano
nella storia punto arriveranno piano
piano è si presenteranno capi grazie
media di questi persona qualcuno si è
accorto dei capelli corti però la
fotogallery
ma mi sento veramente siete dissi musi e
si vide la faglia si capisce non le
gabelle corte del tuo personaggio
anzi ho anche perché avevamo gravi
carito te sì ma li avevo già detto che
avrei avuto i capelli corti allora in
realtà vi spiego questa cosa fa se non
si era capita molto non si capisce molto
dalla sigla io i capelli corti è vitale
è un po diverso ovviamente perché in
realtà siamo noi da piccoli risotto non
siamo noi alla nostra età attuale siamo
piccolini ecco perché io sono così bello
perché lì niente lo metto però dove
berlino
caricano disgrazia che faccio il caso di
dormire pensando cosa fare a parlare di
tale benissimo allora è bellissima la
serie grazie
c'è anche morire nella serie no lo
lanciò la domanda che mi avete più poco
in assoluto
come mai avete scelto frutto questa
canzone allora la canzone la comporta
enrico ci sono le informazioni a punto
nella descrizione non l'ho composta io
sto piangendo mi piace tutto tutto della
serie la steri stupenda non è krona
serie la sigla sigla della serie però
sono veramente contenta che di caccia
mettete farà pure in repeat cantate la
se volete mandate via anche mandatemi
anche i vostri video mentre la cantante
quale sigla anno so se forse non è
arrivata la notifica ad alcuni comunque
c'è la sigla sul canale poi vai a
vederla sono per entrata come state bene
grave e voi come state
quindi forse preso i personaggi si sara
merlino ormai presto arriverà un nuovo
video berlino fontana il domani sarà
anche un video challandes sempre con me
pieno quindi mi raccomando attivate la
campanella via dora grazie
non ho fatto in tempo a leggere zitti
quando vorrei che ha per ora non lo so
tra l'altro tuzi stato a verona mi ha
detto che è bellissima e bellissima
canta una canzone canta un pezzo della
canzone di questa zona cantante da
quando la palla ma non siamo bravi
perché la cantata una cantante perché
siamo spronati detto piace tantissimo
però berlino berlino siete mito tre
feriti gravi adoriamo ovviamente in
sardegna c'era scritto forse sì la forza
intendeva ovvero e presto
quanto durerà questa live noi lo
sappiamo non tantissimo perché tv
preferiti che carini allora
approfittatene ora per farci le domande
sulla serie merlino tutti caduti ma
migliorando i personaggi che dorme
glielo facciamo vedere a giuliano finale
consisterà allora si vede
basta poco poco lo vedete google doti
che foto solo da dormendo berlino
perdono maledetti
bene ora che avete visto merlino
diteci pure qualche domanda sulla serie
oppure vi posso fare anch'io qualche
domanda credo mondo potrebbe farli mai
scritta tu no la scritta il compositore
non l'ho scritta io c'era un commento
processo insomma la serie qui tra sito
pokémon che ora andranno allora non
c'entrano in pokémon però ci sono gli
animali
sapete che la mia passione per gli
animali doveva essere incluso
assolutamente cosa fate dopo la live
andiamo a mangiare chi ha avuto l'idea
tuo vitale in realtà l'abbiamo avuta io
e mio fratello c'è scritto vitale
scriverai mai un suo libro
oddio quante stagioni si saranno
perdonati la modalità una lenta la
modello diventa allora perché altrimenti
è impossibile o del tracciamento delle
sale cinema la prima volta quindi non
sappiamo a me non appare purtroppo
questa modalità topshop proprio delle
qui è comparso qualcosa in arancione ma
non voglio appunto annoiarvi cercando
costava funzionali lasciato io colpo mio
è colpa digitale p
nel frattempo diteci qualche domanda di
cosa parla da serie è una storia
fantastica in cui combatteremo anche
andremo in vari pianeti ci saranno
tantissime cose trasformazioni magia
sarà bellissimo non vedo l'ora
qual è il prossimo video allora il
prossimo video sarà domani sto pensando
ma in effetti potrei spoiler harlow a
voi che siete già in là perché siete
quindi ve lo meritate
allora vi di domani sarà vi ricordate la
silence tre colori di pennarelli lì però
li sceglierà merlino perché i libri li
prendeva ok voleva mangiare è stato
troppo divertenti dove anzitutto quando
comincerà verso fine giugno vi farò
vedere vi farò vi darò la data esatta
per sony personaggi chi sono ci siamo io
e vitale e questo i personaggi a che ora
pubblicherai la serie penso al solito
orario 22 e mezzo se non cambia da
pachino a giugno sarò sempre alle due e
mezzo conto via ma del cielo scritto
tutto quanto ci avete messo per fare la
sigla dicono allora la stile
realizzata io ma l'ha realizzata appunto
mio fratello con il suo collega manuele
e ci hanno messo poco male
sembra facile una cosa che lo vedi anche
non solo questa sigla contro anche
quando andato magari a vedere il film al
cinema di animazione
sembra facile ma è difficilissimo
bisogna usare vari programmi si vuole un
sacco di tempo è molto più difficile di
quello che stai bravi è vero se qualche
sono le puntate dobbiamo ancora vedere
forse otto gli fa gli auguri auguri
comunque loteria ma l'abbiamo visto il
messaggio che vi saluta richiamo d'aria
ciao tenga allora sì ci saranno anche i
video normali non vi preoccupate solo
una volta ogni due settimane si sarà
l'episodio della serie per il resto i
video ci saranno sempre è vi ricordo che
il lunedì e martedì sto caricando nel
secondo canale di suez due invece gli
altri come ogni giorno nel canale
principale sono gelosa di con quello
dice siete fidanzati ci sono gli altri
due dei personaggi della serie che
scoprirete presto di che ratei merlino è
un meticcio quindi mi dicevo dire che è
un insieme di razze si dice anche
bastardino ma non piace questo termine
quindi non è un cane di razza un mix di
razze come italia del canile berlino
farà parlare lei non volevi dire è un
mix di razza come appunto i cani del
canile perché consentito il contrario
asti si perché l'abbiamo preso al canile
era stato abbandonato berlino poi potete
vedere tutta la storia nel video in cui
si intitola che abbiamo adottato un cane
e leeds e tutta la storia di mutismo di
cosa parlo alla serie non ve lo possiamo
ancora dire tutto è così perché
altrimenti vi togliamo tutto il gusto a
rivederla n
oriali questa la domanda di non
accreditare sera abbiamo sofferto nei
nostri video ma avete un nemico qualcosa
già il primo nel primo episodio
vedrete 33 porta iella cattiva è la
gemella cattiva nascosti nei scozia
nascosta per lettera non è la gemella
cattiva il levico e nale 1 nella serie
intendo nella serie animata e monica
story 2 bryan la sua serie tv preferita
è il trono di spade ma non guardate al
city piccolini perché non va bene
poi dai lati qualche altra domanda che
tra poco andiamo che stiamo veramente
vorrebbe si sa in italiano nel testo
resi vivi perché proprio italiano in
realtà è spesso mi dicono che non sempre
italiana conosciuti ma anche detto nel
re la spieghiamo nel video in cui tu
risponde il rischio sia anche quella per
ora fate situate sulla serie sulla sigla
perché non so quando altro potrò
rispondervi perché nello spazio perché
volevamo fare un qualcosa in cui ogni
volta si cambiano un po scenario e c'era
un qualcosa di nuovo ogni volta quindi
nello spazio perché ci saranno vari
pianeti e varie così speciale ma per
caso ci sarà qualcuno che si sta
piangendo lorena no
auguri a tutti perché sta bruciando ad
ora non lo sa quanto dura la sigla dura
un minuto e qualche secondo ma ramo vita
che ho visto negli attori che animali si
saranno bari nel nella sigla vedete
giacché animali sistono pensi siete
state attenti avete visto che già ci
sono degli animali nella sigla come si
chiama il capitale il mio nome proprio
vitale non è un nome comune lo so però
stiamo male con la serie dicono quanto
durerà allora per ora sarà una la serie
sto piangendo perché si trova
ora oddio è difficilissimo leggere il
canale tv il canale mangiarsi tema gli
animali sono veri no sono ovviamente
ricreate tutto animato è tutta una serie
animata fingendo stiamo tanto anche noi
che le carriere che bello vederlo lì
attorno alla serie per tutti certo va
bene per tutte le età
proprio non si può mangiare a chi è
venuta l'idea che ho già risposto a me e
mio fratello ma quale serio lett
per chi fosse arrivato adesso e non sa
ancora che cosa sia successo nel durante
tutta la loro tanto si sente sempre
andate a vedere la sigla che ho
pubblicato oggi così capricci capricci
per primo break è meglio perché breve
ciao fede mica che è che su di essere
salutata 1 c'è pizzorne tomizza vero sì
non ha cantato la sigla una ragazza che
canta la sua memoria bravo chi
opinioniste fa sono dell'ottava stazione
di gears 3 allora in aspettativa di
salute perché non ci posso credere
donato 5 euro veramente io no mandateci
niente allora ciao viola e si riconosca
anche perché su instagram iscrivi spesso
quindi ciao grazie veramente non dovevi
allora sinceramente un po delusa dall
ultimo episodio non voglio sperare
niente per chi non l'ha visto comunque
un po deluso dalla morte di uno dei
personaggi più cattivi
tu invece cosa ne pensi ti sta piacendo
ciao ciao ciao ciao federica nuovamente
ciao giulia ciao anna come si chiama il
cattivo non vogliamo darvelo però nella
sigla c'è il cattivo vediamo se entro se
riuscite a capire chi è perché penso che
si capisca perché fa un ghigno malefico
mi piace la piazza anche domande fare
nella serie si sarà sicuramente era
sistema dei filatelisti chiedeteci le
ultime domande perché tra poco abbiamo
uno youtube nella serie a no no servono
i due poi gli altri personaggi però non
sono youtubers di altri personaggi dove
merlino sempre lì che dorme la serie
sarà in 3d si e animazione 3d nel senso
non è il 3d che lo voglio chiedersi
anche perché penso che esista cioè non
penso che si possa comunque è animazione
3d quindi non è animazione classica tipo
biancaneve che così segno ma e
animazione 3d se non sapete
e cos'è andate a vedere la sigla ho
visto nel cattivo sarà vitale però cosa
successe il cattivo il nord italia sarà
buonasera essere i cattivi
mi sembrano molto tempo letto il tuo
nome
la cena al cinema a messina canale
finalmente vitale magro chi ha disegnato
i personaggi sempre mio fratello è il
suo collega manuele ci saranno il
cattivo sarà la nutella ci saranno altri
personaggi si oltre a quelli che avete
visto forse ce ne saranno anche altri e
poi oltre a noi due ci sono gli altri
personaggi che avete visto proprio nella
sigla stiamo leggendo qualche commento
quanti personaggi ci saranno nella serie
abbiamo appena risposto ma pokémon le
scopi che tu che ne pensi vuoi
continuarlo deve assolutamente ritornare
nel nel canale di vitale tra l'altro
vogliono andare a vedere al cinema dei
grillini si smazzano e se l'avete visto
servizi a tutto incontrerete altri
personaggi simili quest'odio sarà
qualcosa di speciale
posso fare una domanda diretta con sé la
sigla come questa sigla sigla è la parte
iniziale della canzoncina la musica la
forte non a tutti è oggi praticamente è
stato lanciato oggi la sigla della nuova
serie a nina animata di anita stories
quel tipo che stava sul trono bravo
giovanni ha indovinata bravo sisti sei
cattivo perché non mi sono date che
poteri armi personaggi ogni domanda
molto interessante
ognuno una vita e riconosce istituita a
fontana c'entra perché ferito 20
gratteri le tante presto core carina nei
commenti o risposta anche ad uno dei
commenti cosa sulla musica che sono io
il canale digitale che fine ha fatto il
tifo sul trono vedo che sta che indovina
mi volete bene certamente certo come vi
vogliamo un bellissimo colore preferito
il mio hai il celeste il ruota il mio
paese deve mai celeste rosso il dritto
il bianco e anche tomatis bianco perlato
primavera ma vitale non fai più video
quando è sotto prossimo video e se ce la
faccio per commentarlo venerdì sabato al
massimo domenica sera viene usato bene
solo uno spoiler loro che sono in live
ok del prossimo mio video legno canale
sarà un video dove ci sara merlino a
questo va detto i games e portiamo
berlino dove lo portiamo i nostri dove
devi andare un altro spoiler è che
berlino si è innamorato e benefits
innamorato di una cagnolina è né troppo
tenera quando line con barra da una
squadra spaccata
meglio che niente questo è il mio canale
mentre se non facciamo confusione tra e
sociale soprattutto il pc
come si chiama vita nella serie si
chiama vitale abbiamo ottenuto i nostri
nomi
the sims di stampo lo sa bene bene
riesco ricomincia anche con the sims
cosa mangiate stasera il chelsea si dice
c ma perché vita le ha mandate troppo
veloce
mi chiamo michael mi saluta ciao michael
il mio libro preferito
harry potter e è amleto di shakespeare
niente ti piace ok va bene stasera molto
formano quasi niente
oggi sono 30 iniziavo il tipo sul trono
è l'unico cattivo
no purtroppo è da addio è difficilissimo
leggere posso fare una domanda
allora siete poi personaggi della serie
2 sì gli altri sono cose personali pochi
personaggi
qual è la vostra pizza preferita con la
mia vita è la classica margherita più
alla marinara anche ecco è molto
sottovalutata ma la marinara non quella
col pesce lesso che perché in ogni
regione che sono tanto diversa che è
quella con il sugo e alice pensare le
buonissima a me invece la pizza
margherita normale alle volte faccio una
pazzia la prendo con la mozzarella di
bufala
ci sono animali cattivi dicevano no
perché gli animali sono degli angeli
tutti gli animali sono degli angeli
scesi in terra per noi siete quindi non
abbiamo voluto fare nessun animale
cattivo perché non esistono gli animali
cattivi sono veramente degli angeli gli
animali quindi animali sono solo buoni
ma spara un cartone che meno un cartone
pro anima quindi ancora meglio perché
nella sigla perché se di quel colore
detto ali sono celeste e vitale giallo e
poi c'è anche una verde insomma dove la
marea nera che ci perseguita dovevamo
per forza includerlo gli altri
personaggi sono youtube
no no magari nel futuro chi sta per ora
no
il testo della sigla bravi asta a
dubitare mangia pronti
andremo subito come è venuta l'idea
della serie già risposto che è venuta a
me il mio fratello e potevano fare
qualcosa di creativo e di diverso più
mio fratello e supera fosse nato di
animazione 3d quindi era un'ottima
occasione per farlo uscire su youtube o
le torno a domande sulla scritta in
grande posso mangiare spesso come
mangiare ti preoccupare chiusi tutta per
mangiare farò lo stesso anch'io ciao ci
saranno gli animali della serie
ovviamente sì perché sapete che gli
animali permesso importante
bella maglietta vince grazie e qualcosa
scritto prima quanto costa la tua
maglietta non mi ricordo per la
comunione per salutare faccio gli auguri
e saluti
ma veniamo mangiamo mangiare posso fare
una domanda
aggiungo io cosa fare cosa va da chi ha
vinto tipo quello già annunciato stia
nel video l'ho messo nella descrizione
nel commenti sia su internet ma a breve
ne farò un altro perché vi è piaciuto un
tacco quando ci sarà una prossima
puntata
stato il vostro film preferito
tantissimi diciamo e riposi tale domanda
oddio bello bello il porcellino
borsellino di tre story
oddio segugia in line da 30mila volare
incredibile come vuole il tempo quando
ci si diverte e quando stiamo tutti
assieme a leggere una domanda ho letto
solo toccherete poi si non bastano a
gestire ovviamente ho visto la siria
perché chi è il cattivo spoiler non ho
capito bene forse io devo lo spoiler
succhiare il cattivo
[Musica]
ma che cos'è questo che cosa non so cosa
è successo allora guarda dureranno di
episodi diciamo che non lascia questo
aspetto questo non tantissimo per i
capelli corti nella serie perché lo ha
detto all'inizio di questa l'ipad è
perché non siamo noi
attualmente quindi grandi ma siamo noi
da piccolini quindi regioni che vada
ancora a scuola come voi capello mi
saluti mi chiamo i doliri salutate ciao
ciao berlino che dorme berlino sta forma
allora di noi tra poco chiudiamo perché
siamo già al aridha 31 minuti è volato
il tempo veramente polato saperlo
guardiani ato fratello indovinate
vediamo se colpe l'indovina vi faccio
vedere il mattino così lo potete
stampare devono svegliare per poi
chiedergli la scorreggia casa mia
[Musica]
berlino ciao a tutti va bene
non ci si sveglia 13 ma chi è questo
momento guardando nel computer è uguale
a me dai saluto ho salutato saluto tutti
scorreggione peruta ad allora ri apple e
noi vi salutiamo è stato bellissimo fare
questa live
qualcuno ha scritto chi ha o pizzo
uscito da do io direi su sì con
l'avvocato però 30 pesce abbiamo
mangiato ieri sera per vedere per
regolare i soci vegetariano ovviamente
allora ciao anita vitale cia ora visti
ammettiamolo velocemente si novità
blaiotta umano e giancarlo barbadoro 70
anni ha detto qualcuno 29 tuo fratello
ci siamo quasi aprire giovani e carine
sono sentiamo paolo trenta premi luoghi
è stato veramente bellissimo fare il
live con voi e sono felicissima che vi
sia piaciuta tantissimo la sigla
continuate ad ascoltarla se volete
mandati c su instagram i vostri video
cantate ma per il vieri pubblico
l'elettore ma noi siamo felicissimi solo
di vedervi cantare all'alt inail
superbello berlino sta giocando qualcosa
vi ringraziamo tanto per essere venuti
qui a questa live passare questa
mezz'ora e fa con noi e che bello troppo
bello vedervi qualcuno noi comunque noi
ora andiamo a mangiare perché abbiamo
seriamente fa missy ma non perdetevi il
video di domani che sarà la tre colori
di pennarelli salentino
noi li vogliamo troppo bene ma razzola
bracciano abbracciamo tutti